sébastien dufour justement a suivi ces
trois derniers jours jean-louis un
retraité partie damien et qui est un se
rend à bruxelles aujourd'hui immersion
aujourd'hui le dispositif rentrer en
belgique c'est d'être le plus normale
possible au niveau des véhicules d'un
signe distinctif donc
drapeau autre est de pouvoir jeudi
rentrée en tant que véhicules
particuliers sans sans signe distinctif
maintenant
on attend beaucoup de monde est
effectivement il ya deux tous les pays
et donc européen il ya des concours qui
sont partis
et je pense que c'est énorme c'est
l'année au plus près d'aller au hockey
du parlement européen c'est là où sont
prises de décisions de jeudi donc
européenne toutes ces décisions center
qui nous ont ils été gardé pendant
pendant des mois et puis depuis deux ans
sur le dos de bonnes choses
et bien bruxelles nous allons jeter à
portée de vue scénique elle
en a rien à se reprocher on est là on
est pacifique on a en a pas d'armes on
n'a rien du tout en acte de bonne foi
qu'est ce que tu veux qu'ils me disent
je manifeste pas j'ai pas de signes
ostentatoires de drapeaux etc la
raconter ce qui s'est passé par eelv a
été horrible horrible on a vidé chose
d'inadmissible bien terminer en entre
avila et
ils ont lâché les chiens
en plus bravo moi je te dis tu viens de
perpignan
est parti quand toi
mercredi 14 ans que j'étais rouillé pour
les quinze jours
et donc on reconnaît sur la route
arriver une solidarité wen est
incroyable magnifique on a pleuré c'est
dingue
elle préférerait revenus
[Musique]
asseyez on met à bruxelles c'est
extraordinaire les transports il est
comme ça sans encombre
c'est tout s'est bien passé on est dans
les temps on va au parlement le drapeau
européen il avait juste devant nous la
main pleine face
c'est l'épicentre de la technocratie
européenne
mais après ça peut être un épicentre de
la constestation européenne aussi des
peuples
notre revendication principale c'est
dans la liberté la liberté la liberté de
pouvoir je dire dans tous les pays
d'europe pouvoir vivre sans pass
sanitaire vaccinale et autres sans
contrainte et avoir une liberté d'action
et de vivre et son lit brut de pouvoir
vivre normalement notre vie donc dans
chaque pays